[Music]
on this wednesday night
accusations of a cover-up what a new
treasure trove of documents into the wii
charity deal reveals and doesn't reveal
another email all blacked out plus the
fresh scrutiny the prime minister faces
with parliament on pause west coast
wildfires
bc's ballooning blaze there's so many
houses up there and it was just racing
down the hills
and california's catastrophe during a
blistering heat wave
the historic night for the democrats in
delaware our jackson prosco was there
and when push came to shove new evidence
into what started this
courtside confrontation
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
sophie louie good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin with accusations of
a cover-up in ottawa
with new details emerging in the we
charity controversy
just as parliament is pro-roguing late
yesterday the government finally
released
thousands of pages of internal records
linked to the now canceled
we agreement but with parliament now
pro-rogued until late september
the committees investigating the
proposed contract
can't formally review them as they've
been shut down
conservatives say it's clear the prime
minister has something to hide
this page blacked out this page
blacked out this page blacked out
why don't we ask what's in those pages
at a parliamentary committee
well i'll tell you why justin trudeau
shut down those parliamentary committees
when did he do it the same day these
documents became public
what a coincidence
well some of the documents are redacted
but there are still
some key new revelations about how the
we deal came together
global's abigail beeman has more on what
we've learned
and the questions that are still
unanswered
[Applause]
[Music]
at the center of this controversy a big
question how
close was we to the government and why
didn't they register to lobby until the
very day
executives testified at committee in a
may 7
email a finance official writes we is
connecting with minnow that's the
minister's office
they are all besties while the enormous
document trove backs up the government's
assertion that the public service
recommended we
the professional nonpartisan public
service made a recommendation
i accepted it they suggest the minister
responsible bartish chagger
helped shepherd the process according to
emails chagger met with we on april 17th
two days later unemployment and social
development canada official sent an
urgent email to we co-founder craig
kielberger
asking for a quick conversation on a
potential initiative
and on april 22nd kielberger wrote
chagger
we appreciate your thoughtful offer to
connect us with relevant members of your
ministry
over the weekend our team has also been
hard at work to adapt
your suggestion of a second stream
focused on a summer service opportunity
chagger pushed back telling global news
she didn't direct we to change or add to
any proposal
meanwhile the prime minister said
repeatedly he pressed pause on the we
deal on may 8
because he wanted more due diligence
done let's put the brakes on
let's check let's go do extra
verifications
but on that very day a note from a
bureaucrat suggests a different reason
rachel wernick wrote the item just got
bumped to next week
ran out of time delays launch trudeau's
office tells us they stand by his
testimony
and there have been a lot of questions
about where that 900 million dollar
number for the student grant program
came from three weeks after it was
announced a finance official wrote
there is no breakdown it was
unbelievably preliminary
with actually no model of how it would
be administered
while the assistant deputy minister
referred to the lucy goosey logic
used to come up with it the lobby and
commissioner tells us they've launched a
preliminary
assessment but won't comment as to
whether an investigation
is underway while the rcmp stepped up
their language in a new statement
telling global news they're examining
this matter carefully
and will take appropriate actions as
required
abigail beeman global news ottawa
all right let's bring in our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson mercedes
let's talk about that rcmp statement
what do you make of it well sophie
that's the question
what does it mean and for our viewers i
wanted to share exactly what it is that
we
asked the rcmp we asked if they could
confirm whether they're investigating
the liberal government's decision to
award a contract
to the we charity foundation and to
administer that 900 million dollar
federal student grant program
their response is carefully worded but
stronger than before
they say the rcmp is examining this
matter carefully with all available
information
and will take appropriate actions as
required it would be inappropriate for
us to provide
any more further comments on this time
at this ma on this matter at this time
now sophie that does not mean that they
have launched a criminal
investigation but it does mean that
they're taking a look
to decide if this is something they
should move forward with and that
obviously is a development
especially after the rcmp were asked to
investigate by the conservatives
of course the police don't respond to
any political party they make their own
decisions all right you've been pouring
over these documents as well mercedes
what other questions do they raise
well questions that we really won't get
an answer to with the pro-roguing of
parliament because the committees have
been suspended that we're looking
at these documents questions about
ministerial involvement like you just
heard about in
abigail story questions about whether
ministers were honest at committees
whether any of the lobbying that was
happening was potentially illegal
and of course questions about bill
morneau who's now departed
all of this has been shot down which
stops the momentum
and takes the pressure off the
government that's been a tried and true
formula for former prime ministers in
trouble
who have also used prorogation as a
technique to take the heat off
including prime minister harper and
prime minister krachan
what's unique about this is that we're
not talking about pro-roguing
during a majority but rather a minority
and during a pandemic
that said it's not for very long and the
government promises a confidence vote
so is there a risk mercedes of bringing
down the government and perhaps
triggering an election
there's always a risk but frankly the
risk to the liberals at this point is
low as long as they can keep
one of the opposition parties on board
because of the way the breakdown is in
the house of commons
the most likely to stay on board is jug
meat singh and the ndp
and a lot of the language that was used
yesterday by the government signals
they're looking at significant spending
i asked mr singh today about whether or
not what is revealed in these we
documents
that now can't be examined at committee
until the fall has changed his mind on
whether or not he'll support the
government
this is what he had to say look at the
question of
confidence or not our focus is on what
do people need right now and what i'm
hearing from people from families
they want to know that their kids can go
back to school safely they want access
to child care
they want to know that they're going to
be able to rely on something like serb
or ei that's expanded those are the
passing things and i want to focus on
that
doesn't sound like a party leader
looking to bring down the government but
of course it'll depend
on what they can negotiate with the
liberals sophie all right mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thank you mercedes
well taking over as finance minister of
a g7 economy is a tall order for anyone
under
any circumstances but taking on the role
during a pandemic adds a whole new set
of challenges
new figures out today show canada's
inflation rate has slowed
the consumer price index fell to 0.1
percent
in july with lower prices for gas and
air travel
dragging that number down our chief
political correspondent david aiken
has been sizing up the situation and
reports on the task
facing the country's new finance
minister
the economic challenge created by the
coronavirus
christian freeland begins her historic
tenure with economics
and politics stacked against her an
unemployment rate not seen in 25 years
with more than one in 10 workers out of
a job
a sky-high deficit projected to hit an
all-time record
of more than 340 billion dollars and
with a recent
credit rating downgrade canada's lenders
are skeptical
i think the the most important thing to
say is to be bold
this is not a time for half measures
indeed both freeland and the prime
minister hinted on tuesday
that their plan will in fact contain
bold measures
with a green environmental theme there's
going to be enormous pressure on her
clearly from her colleagues particularly
her boss
to spend a lot a lot more now later on
the tricky politics it comes with a
minority government
already taking on water over the we
charity scandal
and the pressure on freeland is even
greater we're in a global pandemic
we're in recessionary times canadians
are worried about paying the bills
feeding their families
and justin trudeau is completely
preoccupied
with the scandals for freeland to
succeed
and return canada to prosperity the
country has to get back to work
so let's make sure the spending that
we're going to be incurring is about
building confidence in this economy and
getting people back to work
not giving them incentives to stay at
home but how do you make the change from
the serb
to a new employment insurance system
that will support a return to work in a
time of pandemic
lots of canadians incomes are going to
be dependent on how she and her
colleagues deal with that challenge
women and minorities are
disproportionately unemployed and
that means freeland will have to keep
spending to help those groups back to
work
and that inevitably means more money for
child
care now is really the time to deliver
because
our economic recovery depends on it so
that's
you know the first step the next step
though comes september 23rd
a throne speech that will have
freeland's roadmap
for economic recovery david aiken global
news
ottawa the new premier of newfoundland
and labrador is inheriting a troubling
financial situation too
and today andrew fury was sworn into his
new role
fury a surgeon and charity ceo with no
political experience must tackle a 2.1
billion dollar deficit due to plummeting
oil prices
and pandemic spending to help with a
fresh start the new premier unveiled his
cabinet
adding three new faces he says he's
optimistic about the province's
potential
but acutely aware of the challenges that
lie ahead
we're in tough times but we'll get out
of it together as long as we all work
together
every single person in this province has
a role to play in the recovery that's
going to happen over the next few years
fury must win a seat in the legislature
within the next 12 months he says he
intends to run for the next
available seat it's going to be a
nervous night for people living in parts
of british columbia
wildfires are raging out of control in
the province's interior and on vancouver
island
nearly 90 wildfires have started in the
past two days
many of them likely caused by dry
lightning strikes earlier this week
many of those fires are in the okanogan
valley and in the kootenai region
and the wildfire risk remains high or
extreme throughout the southern portion
of the province
one fire near penticton grew so quickly
it engulfed 10 square kilometers in just
a matter of hours
global bc's aaron macarthur is on the
ground in the okanagan
where nearly 3 700 properties are under
evacuation alert
erin sophie cooler temperatures today
giving crews a chance to get
hopefully get a handle on this fire but
last night bad news
at least one home destroyed by flames
it's terrifying to watch the raging fire
clearly visible to people in penticton
people here are ready for the fire
season evacuation orders
still filled with emotion there's so
many houses up there and it was just
racing down the hill so
we'll see if we have a house in the days
to come
all logged off in behind there if it
gets into those plantations in the dry
grass it's really going to spread
and this wind isn't going to help the
terrain
rocky and steep difficult for ground
crews to make any progress
wednesday a parade of helicopters dipped
in skaha lake
bucketing a section of the fire right on
top of dozens of homes
for at least one homeowner it's too late
the home destroyed overnight by flames
now is the time to make sure you have a
plan
for your family and your pets so that
you don't have a situation where
someone's knocking on the door and
you're saying
i'm not ready to go the fire has
continued to spread
the bc wildfire service pins the size at
about 1400 hectares and continuing to
grow
the fight to save homes a long way from
being finished
this fire is far from contained it means
hundreds of people will
not likely be going home anytime soon
and thousands of people
ready to go at a moment's notice
sophie erin mcarthur in bc for us thank
you erin
california's wine country is dealing
with its own wildfire
emergency thousands have been told there
is an immediate threat to their lives
[Music]
several thousand homeowners in the city
of vacaville
west of sacramento have been ordered to
leave the governor declared a state of
emergency for all of california
as multiple blazes incinerate at least
18
thousand hectares of land in the napa
and sonoma valleys
an even larger complex of fires is
burning around the san francisco
bay area and smoke is covering much of
central and
northern california it's believed most
of the fires were caused by lightning
storms
on the heels of record-breaking hot
weather
the mission to vote out donald trump
coming up democrats and even some
republicans
on why joe biden should be america's
next president
it'll be a moment for the history books
in the u.s tonight at the democratic
national convention
as kamala harris accepts her nomination
for vice president in the race to unseat
president donald trump
our jackson prescott joins us from
wilmington delaware
presidential candidate joe biden's home
base jackson what are we expecting from
the convention tonight
well sophie tonight's convention will
focus on threats to the american
constitution and american way of life
former president barack obama is set to
speak from philadelphia outlining what
he calls the grave choice facing
american voters
while here in wilmington kamala harris
will address the history being made
by including her on a presidential
ticket
at this unconventional convention a few
socially distanced delegates will watch
kamala harris make history
when she speaks as the first woman of
color to be a vice presidential
candidate
harris takes the stage on a night that
will include speeches from former
president barack obama
and former presidential candidate
hillary clinton
all of them making the case for why joe
biden should be president
32 years after he mounted his first
attempt at a presidential campaign
biden officially became his party's
nominee on tuesday
joe biden joe biden joe biden
after a night that saw a 50-state
virtual roll call
and an impassioned speech to americans
from his wife
jill biden he will do for your family
what he did for ours bring us together
and make us whole the united states of
america this first of its kind
convention has focused on made for tv
moments
aimed at selling biden as a
compassionate competent and experienced
candidate
not too extreme and uniquely suited to
this era of crisis
endorsements have come from republicans
too like former secretary of state colin
powell
even as biden opens the door to the
party's growing progressive wing
and the fact is everybody wants to get
to the same place
our country is in a very serious even
existential crisis
and we need a very different president
when biden delivers his own address on
thursday from that same stage
it will be to a party united
jackson you talked about made for tv
moments with this being a virtual
convention
are people still tuning in and paying
attention
yeah sophie nearly 30 million viewers
tuned in last night between tv and
online the tv ratings are down about 25
percent from the last convention four
years ago
online interest though has gone through
the roof and that's why you're seeing
this convention rolled out
in these quick moving segments which are
easily shared through social media
all right thanks for that jackson prosco
in wilmington delaware
well many are likely using their apple
devices to tune into the convention
the tech giant reached a huge milestone
today
apple has become the first u.s company
to be worth
two trillion dollars to put their
success into perspective
it took apple 42 years to reach a value
of one trillion dollars that was in
august of 2018.
it took only two more years to get to
two trillion
even more interesting apple's second
trillion came in just the past
21 weeks while the global economy shrank
due to the pandemic customers continued
to purchase products
online in record numbers while stores
were closed
apple shares have soared almost 60
percent this year and
are at an all-time high trading at 470
dollars a share
ahead giving alberta an economic boost
during the pandemic
the new finance minister's commitment to
a green economic recovery
is very much at odds with the strategy
out west
alberta's restart has put resource
development front and center not only
with investment into the oil and gas
sector
but with new efforts to attract
investment in coal mining
heather urex west explains in its
foothills and rocky mountains alberta's
government sees an opportunity for
economic growth
we have in canada a very strong coal
industry
a lot of it is is metallurgical coal or
sometimes called steel making coal
which is really required to make steel
until now most of canada's steel making
coal has come from bc
the alberta government is trying to get
into the game removing restrictions last
month that have banned open pit mines in
many sensitive areas of the province
since the 1970s that protected about 1.5
million hectares
of sensitive rocky mountain habitat all
right and
this area is is not just important for
habitat for fair fish and wildlife
but it is also the source water for most
of alberta
and downstream into the prairies ottawa
has committed to phasing out
the use of thermal coal the kind used to
produce electricity by
2030. it will have to decide whether it
supports new
steel making coal developments when the
proposed grassy mountain coal project in
southwest alberta
comes up for federal approval later this
year i think all canadians
understand that the restart
of our economy needs to be green the new
finance minister's comments wednesday
that environmental interests will be a
priority moving forward
have already sparked concern a
spokesperson for the alberta premier
said wednesday
we are concerned that in the middle of
this uncertainty
some in ottawa seem more interested in
risky and expensive economic experiments
any talk of economic recovery is
incomplete
without canada's energy sector an
industry that has taken
a massive hit this year the oil and gas
industry is ready to step
up and do our part in pulling us out of
this
this situation and to do it in a way
that's environmentally responsible is
certainly a challenge that we're up for
it's a balancing act that has not been
easy for ottawa in the past
and it won't get any easier under the
impact of covid19
heather urex west global news calgary
courtside countersuit next new video
plays in favor of the raptors role
in an nba battle
and there's a big development in a legal
battle involving raptors president
masaya jiri
for more than a year he has faced
accusations he assaulted a sheriff's
deputy after last year's championship
game
but new video has emerged telling a very
different story
footage from the deputy's body camera
shows ujiri trying to get onto the court
to celebrate
when the deputy forcefully shoves him
twice
before ujiri pushes back the deputy
alan strickland says zujiri assaulted
him after he tried to stop ujjiri
because he didn't see the proper
credentials that deputy has since sued
ajiri claiming the alleged
assault caused him great emotional and
physical pain
he's seeking nearly 100 thousand dollars
in damages plus
other compensation in a countersuit
filed this week gujiri's lawyers call
strickland's lawsuit frivolous and
motivated by greed
they say the video shows strickland was
undeniably the initial aggressor
raptors head coach nick nurse responded
to the video
to me it's pretty self-explanatory
you know um and and
and disappointing it's been a long time
it's been over a year right so it's good
to kind of
maybe get get close to some closure on
that
global news reached out to the sheriff's
office for comment they say the video
released
doesn't tell the full story that's
global national for this wednesday i'm
sophie louie tonight's your canada is
from saskatchewan's prince albert
national park
thanks for watching have a great night
[Music]